[Musica]
buongiorno pensate che io volevo
cominciare il mio intervento facendovi
delle domande quelle domande a cui si
risponde alzando alla mano mi sembrava
un'idea di quelle poco che dovevano
spaccare stamattina ho scoperto che chi
mi precedeva aveva avuto la mia stessa
idea
sono entrato in disperazione non sapevo
cosa fare allora ho chiesto agli
organizzatori e loro credo solo per
consolarmi mi hanno detto ma no no
perché se le persone alzano e abbassano
la mano fanno movimento fisico
questo fa bene al corpo fa bene alla
mente e così ho detto va bene allora
cominciò così magari quello che racconto
non interesserà nessuno ma almeno ha
fatto ginnastica e mi sono grati ok
allora vi prego di cominciare
rispondendo ad una domanda e la domanda
è una domanda per certi versi anche un
po angosciante
siete soddisfatti del vostro lavoro così
e così
se io provo a renderlo un po più dura
questa domanda siete totalmente
soddisfatti del vostro lavoro
qualcuno cioè totalmente complimenti
invece poi chiudo quell'ultima di malta
così finiamo la ginnastica
pensate che il vostro lavoro possa
essere reso migliore grazie vi ringrazio
perché perché questo è il tema di cui
vorrei parlare il gioco crafting che
possiamo tradurlo con la parola
personalizzazione del lavoro ed è
un'idea manageriale un po pazza che dice
che se noi permettiamo ai lavoratori
autonomamente di modificare il contenuto
del loro lavoro i lavoratori sono
sicuramente più soddisfatti ma la
produttività l'efficienza dell'azienda
non solo non ne subisce un danno ma
addirittura può migliorare questa è
l'idea del job crafting utopia follia
prova a convincere chi mi ha detto sì ad
utopia prova a raccontarvi un esempio
che secondo me ci fa capire di cosa si
tratta
ospedale ahimé non era italiano ma anche
in italia abbiamo questo problema che ha
un problema particolare la pulizia la
pulizia di corridoio la polizia di bagni
e la pulizia delle camere non sono
abbastanza puliti che cosa vi viene in
mente per risolvere questo problema
mettiamo dei controlli mettiamo un capo
a controllare la gente che pulisce
oppure un'altra soluzione un pochino più
carina ma sempre di quelle che vengono
dall'alto
diamo un incentivo se saranno più puliti
bagni vi daremo un premio e invece no la
direzione di questo ospedale ha avuto
un'idea originale ha chiesto ai
lavoratori che fanno un lavoro
umidissimo pulire gli spazi di un
ospedale ma voi cosa vorreste fare
e chiaro che non li puoi lasciare
totalmente liberi ma cosa vorreste fare
e queste persone hanno detto dopo aver
fatto degli incontri delle riunioni dopo
aver riflettuto hanno detto questa cosa
noi vorremmo provare a partecipare al
processo di cura vorremmo sentirci più
importanti di quello che siamo oggi
facendo solo pulizie e quindi hanno
studiato qualcosa in cui potevano
intervenire credo che nessuno di noi
sarebbe contento di farsi fare una
puntura una visita da parte di una
persona che fa le pulizie ma hanno
aiutato a questo processo di cura né
cominciato a fare questa cosa e sapete
cosa è successo magicamente che i bagni
erano puliti i corridoi erano
scintillanti era cresciuta la
motivazione di queste persone ma è
cresciuta anche l'efficienza
dell'impresa ecco io mi vorrei proporre
una mission impossible cercare di
convincere il maggior numero possibile
mi accontento di uno tra i presenti
qualcuno che magari dirige un'impresa è
un imprenditore eccetera che dando
spazio ai collaboratori si possono
ottenere dei vantaggi imprenditoriali
questo è il gioco gratis
ok e il gioco crafting una
personalizzazione che cosa possiamo
personalizzare possiamo personalizzare
tre cose 3 paroloni inglesi scusate il
gioco crafting può essere il task
crafting significa permettere al
lavoratore di cambiare il contenuto del
proprio lavoro senza danneggiare la
produttività imprenditoriale
un altro caso bellissimo cerco di
raccontarvi dei casi così mi crederete
che si può fare è quello delle cassiere
erano tutte donne quindi andiamo al
femminile delle cassiere di un
supermercato
cos'è il lavoro di una cassiera oggi
prendi un oggetto lo passi su un lettore
ottico queste cassiere lo facevano come
tante persone come credo sia
l'esperienza di tutti noi neanche
vediamo la faccia di chi ci sta davanti
come la cassiera non vede la nostra
faccia
ebbene a queste cassiere e stato chiesto
ma o meglio sono loro che hanno chiesto
possiamo migliorare il nostro lavoro
vorremmo dare dei suggerimenti ai nostri
clienti
se ci pensate quello che ci succede ogni
giorno non so quanti di voi hanno fatto
degli acquisti online appena provate a
digitare il titolo di un libro o un
oggetto vi arrivano dieci suggerimenti
di prodotti correlati che possono
piacere perché c'è un algoritmo dietro
ecco le cassiere hanno studiato degli
algoritmi che non erano solo commerciali
erano anche dei consigli se vi comperato
i broccoletti guarda che li puoi
cucinare così eccetera e hanno
incominciato autorizzati dalla direzione
aziendale a dare consigli ai clienti
avevano imparato degli schemi per
gestire questa cosa
ebbene il supermercato ha sofferto un po
in termini di efficienza di efficienza
no è chiaro che perdevano un po più di
tempo ma la fidelizzazione dei clienti
che invece di essere messi magari come
avviene oggi nei supermercati a fare la
cassa da soli ricevevano questo tipo di
feedback ad a puntare il risultato che
il supermercato è stato ben contento di
farlo o apro una piccola parentesi vi ho
parlato di addetti alle pulizie vi ho
parlato di cassiere non è che il job
crafting si fa solo sui livelli
operativi
c'è qualche fiscalista qui in sala
no posso parlare male quindi non c'è
problema non è un bel mestiere siete
d'accordo con me e ben noioso
ecco ci sono c'era e c'è qualche
fiscalista nascosto chiedo perdono
ecco il fiscalista che decide
improvvisamente di dare suggerimenti di
tipo strategico di tipo organizzativo di
tipo marketing al proprio cliente sta
allargando il suo tasca
e questo il primo una secondo modalità
di personalizzazione il relation claque
rafting la possibilità di scegliere le
persone con cui lavorare
ora ci sono alcuni fortunati che sono
ben in alto nella gerarchia che scelgono
con chi lavorare ma la maggior parte dei
lavoratori non possono scegliere con chi
lavorano e magari si trovano a lavorare
con persone che non sono le persone che
gli stanno più a genio
pensate noi non possiamo fare nome ma
che c'è un'industria di elettrodomestici
multinazionale americana lasciava
immaginare quale sia che consente agli
operai dei team di fare l'ultimo
colloquio agli operai che si pensa di
assumere affinché loro possano dire mi
piace non mi piace la terza categoria di
job traffica un po strana è la più
semplice anche la più difficile
nello stesso tempo perché questa è far
sì che uno abbia una percezione diversa
del proprio lavoro che lo consideri una
cosa importante è la più semplice perché
lo facciamo nella nostra testa non
abbiamo bisogno di aiuto di nessuno però
anche la più difficile perché la
facciamo con la nostra testa che la cosa
più difficile da cambiare e per farlo vi
vorrei fare un racconto che non è mio ma
di un mio amico che si chiama walter e
che pensate è un maestro shaolin è uno
dei pochissimi maestri shaolin
occidentali è l'unico maestro shaolin
italiano vive in svizzera che esista al
mondo disciplina cinese
lui racconta sempre questo episodio che
quando è andato nel tempio dove si
impara la disciplina shaolin c'è un
lungo una lunga strada che porta al
tempio dove ci sono dei cestini
dell'immondizia ed ogni mattina c'è un
vecchietto con un carretto orrendo
costruito da lui ruote di bicicletta
raccolti in giro che vuote e cestini li
prende lì lucida e li rimette a posto e
lui ha detto ma è mai possibile che un
uomo di quest'età debba fare lo spazzino
e questi gli han detto ma lui non è uno
spazzino noi qui abbiamo gli strumenti
adatti per fare la pulizia lui è un
maestro e lui ha pensato il maestro
impazzito si mette a pulire i cestini
ebbene il maestro stava spiegando alle
persone che non conta quello che fai ma
se tu lo fai in un certo modo lo stai
nobilitando
adesso starete pensando che c'entra il
maestro charme in prova un esempio più
vicino non so quanti di voi hanno i
figli che vanno a scuola in questo
momento magari li avete avuti un parente
eccetera
lunedì andate dai bidelli e chiedetegli
qual è il vostro lavoro
se i bidelli vi diranno il nostro lavoro
e spazzare dove le persone sporcano
probabilmente non sono di buon i bidelli
se invece vi diranno facciamo parte
partecipiamo al processo di educazione
creando delle aule degli spazi puliti
ecco queste sono delle persone che hanno
nobilitato il loro lavoro sono riuscito
a convincere qualcuno
spero sempre in uno solo se qualcuno ha
avuto la malaugurata idea di convincersi
corro subito a trattare questo tema ma
si può progettare si può realizzare il
job crafting ecco sembra di sì bisogna
mettere in piedi tre cose primo guardare
in faccia i propri lavoratori
non tutti i lavoratori sono pronti per
fare il gioco crati 1 devono essere
persone con una grande apertura mentale
e delle persone che siano competenti
quelli bravi possono fare giocarti se
avete delle persone che non sono capaci
di fare il loro lavoro come fanno a
migliorare allora guardate in faccia ai
lavoratori se non son bravi fatti di
diventare bravi lasciate perdere sono
bravi aperti e resilienti è dura fare il
job job crafting ci sono le illusioni ci
sono quindi devono accettare le
sconfitte andare avanti seconda cosa e
accelera un attimino ci vuole una
cultura di tipo imprenditoriale e una
cultura poco gerarchica mondo altre
spiegazioni
terzo elemento importantissimo gli
incentivi economici
qualcuno dice questo è un po controverso
bisogna dare dei soldi a chi fa il job
crafting sì o no qualcuno dice che
bisogna darli perché è un modo per
condividere i risultati
qualcun altro dice che invece è già così
bello il gioco crafting che auto
motivante io sinceramente penso alla
prima però c'è un motore di ricerca di
cui non faccio il nome ma che data la
penetrazione di mercato credo che el 80
e passa
per cento di voi utilizzi ogni giorno
che consente ai propri lavoratori di
utilizzare il 20 per cento del proprio
tempo per fare progetti che loro
propongono ai loro capi bene
123 il demone tema dei temi i capi come
l'apprendere hanno di fronte ad
un'ipotesi di joe crafting beh i capi di
solito hanno tre reazioni
la prima lo combattono nella maniera più
forte possibile
la seconda per quieto vivere fanno finta
di non vederlo
la terza partecipano ecco purtroppo
questo sistema funziona si capì non si
mettono di traverso e questo è molto
importante ci vogliono capi che
capiscano che si può avere più successo
valorizzando i collaboratori che facendo
le cose da soli ultimo aneddoto e poi
dopo va dalle conclusioni
voglio raccontarvi la storia di natale
capellaro e la prima storia che racconto
con nomi e cognomi e una storia di tanti
anni fa degli anni trenta natale
capellaro era un apprendista che
lavorava al olivetti nel centro ricerche
e prendeva i pezzi e li componeva come i
grandi pensatori gli chiedevano di fare
un giorno si scopre che c'erano
magari qualcuno di voi conosce questa
storia che c'erano degli ammanchi dei
pezzi mancavano si capiva perché ea quei
tempi hanno mandato il capo di natale
capellaro nella casa di questo giovane
hanno scoperto che il giovane aveva
effettivamente portato via di pezzi ma
con questi aveva composto un prototipo
il capo torna e chiede ad adriano
olivetti di licenziare natale capellaro
e sapete cosa ha fatto degli olivetti
prima lo ha nominato responsabile di una
ore e poi è diventato il direttore delle
ricerche delle olivetti è inventato la
diviso ma forse ne avete sentito parlare
la prima macchina calcolatrice che è
stato introdotta nel nostro paese
quello era un capo pensate il gioco
crafting degli anni 30
adriano olivetti aveva intuito che
poteva essere una grande opportunità per
l'azienda l'altro capo di cui non
facciamo il nome aveva ragionato da capo
che dice oddio mi hanno rubato
ecco poi richiudere con questo gli studi
ultimamente sembrano dirci che le
persone sono sempre più insoddisfatte
sul lavoro ci sono parole come burn out
l'avete già sentita
dieci anni fa non ne parlava nessuno
parole come work life balance o
bilanciamento attività lavorativa
attività di vita erano parole ignote per
tante ragioni perché è diventato più
competitivo il mondo del lavoro più
stressante oggi sono parole attuali ecco
quando siamo in questa situazione cosa
dobbiamo fare dobbiamo contestare il
lavoro dobbiamo cambiare lavoro
dobbiamo rassegnarci essere demotivati
ecco il job crafting vuole essere la
risposta meno violenta o aggressiva a
questo tema e quindi vorrei chiudere
lasciandovi questa questa mia frase se
non puoi fare il lavoro che ami prova ad
amare il lavoro che fai
[Applauso]